that is so cute eight news now is
sponsored by our community pride
partners finley automotive group
southwest medical part of optum care and
silver state schools credit union
findlay automotive group the sponsors of
this next segment are all about cars and
community we know that but today they
want to bring awareness to baby's bounty
in particular
i'm jeff giles with finley automotive
group and the marketing director filling
with for thai recorder today
and we're here at babies bounty as you
can see from this great mural
and babies bounty is a charity that
we're really proud to support
they provide diapers formula and just a
whole lot of things that you need when
you have a baby at home and um you know
personally i actually have a baby at
home right now and uh i'm going through
all of this again it's my third time
through but um and this stuff is just so
essential and important and we're really
just proud to support this charity
because every baby deserves to have the
necessities to have the formula the
diapers and everything that they need
and so you know that's where we're proud
to support baby's bounty and i want to
just introduce you to
uh kelly maxwell the executive director
of baby's bounty and she'll tell you a
lot more about the organization and what
they do so here at babies bounty
the need for diapers
and formula now as well is is
overwhelming
a third of families with
newborns experience diaper need and
that's not having an adequate supply of
diapers and wipes to keep their children
clean safe and dry so that's what we do
here we provide those supplies at last
count we had distributed over
1.65 million diapers and 3.9 million
wipes to over 25 000 of southern
nevada's tiniest residents so we're here
today in our diaper warehouse this
warehouse can hold about 400 000 diapers
when it's full we've had a few diaper
banks recently so we've
used quite a bit of our supply but we're
ramping up again for our next diaper
bank we have one
in north las vegas and another one
coming in in the las vegas area there is
no
replacement for
seeing the gratitude on the faces of the
families that we serve
when you hand them the diapers and wipes
they're grateful there's often tears
they feel relief they're in a panic
situation and it's
the honor of my lifetime to be able to
help
we know for certain we wouldn't be able
to do the good work we're doing in our
community without our tremendous
community partners we count findlay
automotive group as one of those and
we're so grateful for their
participation both financially
and their support coming out visiting
our diaper banks and of course
talking to us about our needs and how
they can help folks can access our
diaper bank by registering online at
babiesbounty.org
we provide a week's supply of diapers to
any family in need we have sizes newborn
all the way through seven and pull-ups
all the way through size 5t so we
purchased these diapers at wholesale
pricing far cheaper than the general
public so if you'd like to donate cash
so that we can purchase those diapers
our website is
babiesbounty.org there's a link to
donate there also because of the need
for baby formula we accept new unopened
cans of baby formula and we will double
check to make sure it wasn't part of the
recall
so important thank you to findlay
automotive group for sponsoring that
segment head to babiesbounty.org for
more information